ya
Ben belirtirler çocuğum
1980 yılının Eylül ayı benim için çok
önemliydi Ortaokulu bitirdiğim Melisa'ya
hazırlandığım Yıllar 13 yaşındayım genç
kızlara aday olduğum günler ilk defa
büyük bir doğum günü kutlamasını
heyecanla bekliyorum akşamdan o sünger
Büyücüler de saçlarımı sardım
hatırlıyorum giyecekleri de yatağımın
başucunda Annem iki katlı pastayı
hazırlamış arkadaşlarımız da çağırırız o
hayallerle akşam uykuya daldım saat 05
sularıydı elle bir telaş bir hareket bir
sesler tam anlamlandırmaya çalışıyorum
ne olduğunu ve babamın anneme
seslenişini duydum Gül ihtilal olmuş
ihtilal ne demektir ki
anlam vermeye o Türkan Salona gittim
sokakta askerler var Serhad türküleri ve
sokağa çıkma yasağı ilan edilmiş o gün
ihtilal benim için doğum günümün elinden
elimden alınmış mıydı sadece Tabii ki
ihtilal kelimesinin yüklediğim anlam
20'li yaşlarımda farklılaştı 30'lu
yaşlarında 40'lı ve 50'li yaşlarında
farklılaştı böyle hayatımı Ben bir
ihtilal çocuğuyum cümlesi de damgasını
vurmuş oldu liseye geçtiğimiz yıllarda
ihtilalin izlerini çok daha fazla
yaşamaya başladık Ben kimim ne olacağım
nereye gidiyorum lütfu soruları sorardık
Birbirimize aslında birazcık galiba
elimizden tutan birilerine ihtiyacımız
vardı dertleşiriz ya Bir Çaresi vardır
ilerde bir şeyler olacak diyen ve okulda
ben çok şanslıydım benim bütün gücüm
yanımdaydı ilham kaynaklarım Sevgili
annem ve babam Babam bir asker evladı
ama işte babam da ve o 1948 ekonomik
krizine çok ciddi izleriyle yaşamış biri
zannediyorum İki Dünya Savaşı sonrası ve
herhalde cumhuriyetin yükselişinde de
mühendis olma kararını ülkesine hizmet
etmek üzere aldı ve gir makine mühendisi
oldu annem biraz Gel kızı 1944 doğumlu
1958 yılındaki ikinci ekonomik krizi O
da en büyük izleriyle yaşamış biri ve
evimizin en yaratıcı en güler yüzlü
ekonomisi Zannederim böyle farklı
zamanlarda ama aynı kaderi yaşamış iki
insanın çocuğu olmaktan sonra 12 Eylül
tarihi benim doğum günüm için bir
tesadüf değil onlar hiçbir zaman dış
şartları suçlanamaz larda evimizde her
zaman ben ne yapabilirim sorusunu
sorardık Kader Diye Bir Şey Vardır bir
şeyin üstünde Durmaz duk bile dolayı o
kendi içimde biri bile şaşırtacak
güçlerim olduğuna inanarak büyüdüm
önemli olan o güçleri keşfetmek sonra
uyandırmak ve eyleme geçirmek olacaktı
İşte o zaman ihtilal içimiz deyiz
oyunlarda dışarıdaki sohbetlerde
gençlerin hayallerimi çalınıyor kısmında
hep bazı sohbetlere arkadaşlarımızla
birlikte kulak kabartıp çok fazla
itibaren etmezdim üstünde durmazdım ama
arkadaşlarımızla yaptığımız o dertli
sohbetlerin dibinde Bunlar vardı ve
onların çok etkilendiğini de görürdüm
biraz o sohbetlerde suskun olmayı
yeğlerdim Belki de geleceğimiz için bir
şeyler Söyleyebilecek elimde materyal
yoktu onun için de susardım
takipçi Aslında aktif bir dinleyici olma
becerisinin hayatıma Hatta geleceğime
yönde bu keşfedene kadar
geleceği düşünürken o yıllarda istemekle
başarmak arasında Aslında zayıf bir
ilişkinin olduğunu da tahmin ediyordum
Tabii ki yani başarılı olmak için
istemek şart bu kesinlikle Ama çok iyi
bir ses sanatçısı Olamazdım Çünkü
hançerleyen bana müsaade etmezdi o zaman
hayatımıza baktığımız zaman başarılı
olabilmek için o içimizdeki tutkuları
becerileri ilgileri entelektüel kısmı
tutkuları ortaya çıkarmak ve bütün
enerjimizi ve oraya akıtmak gerektiği
noktasında çok büyük bir içsel
motivasyon
taşıyordum istediğiniz şeye ne kadar
yatkın olduğunuzu bilmek ve bu
yatkınlığın dış güçler tarafından
Aslında takdir edilmesi teşvik edilmesi
ve Bunu hayatın boyunca olumlu
etkileriyle yaşadın Belki bugün Sizler
Biz hani bu gençliği izleyeceksiniz ve
2050 yıllarda bu dönemin ekonomik sosyal
duygusal tüm yönlerini öğrencilerinize
evlatlarınıza bak sorunlarınızı
anlatıyor olacaksınız ve en önemli şey
aslında yaşam date geçtiğimiz yol
yaşamda
seçeceğimiz yol ya da yaşamda şu ün
yaşadığımıza nasıl anlam verdiğimiz bize
bir avantaj ya da dezavantaj olabilir
80'li yıllarda ben bunları düşünürken
2021'de yıllarda gençler neler düşünüyor
acaba diye çok merak ettim Onun için de
gençlere sordum gerçek hedeflerinize
ulaşabileceğiniz düşünüyor musunuz 15
arasında ölçeklendir dik
sizde Bahar olan becerilerinizi ne
olduğunu gelişmiş olan gecelerinizi ne
olduğuna inanıyorsunuz ikinci soruydu ya
da geliştirilmesi açık becerilerinizi ne
olduğunu inan Bu
grubun 200 kişiye yakın Belki küçük bir
grup ama anlamlı verirler vardı içinde
çok değerli veriler vardı yüzde 91'i
içindeki tutkuyu yakalayıp ona sarılacak
zar alacağım cevabı verdi ölçeklendirme
de biri seçti Bravo size sadece akademik
beceriler gelişmeye açık becerileri ve
kendinde güçlü hissettiği belirler
kısmında biraz 40 karmaşıklık vardır
Çünkü ay öğrenilmesi yetiler ve
yöntemlerle beceriler arasında Kafalar
karışık umurunda söylemeliyim Evet yüzde
sekseni fizikte kimyada biyolojide
çalışma yöntem ve tekniklerinde giriş
meleğim derken
ben iyi bir gözlemci ve detayları
yakalaya biliyorum sorumluluk bilinci
yüksek o kadar kolay psd biliyorum ki
Empati yeteneği güçlü İnsanlarla güzel
ilişkiler kurabiliyorum diyen tanım O da
müthiş buluyorum o zaman bu gençlik
içinde hayalleri Ellerinden ve alınıyor
sorusunun cevabını onlar aslında şu
küçük anketle vermiş olsunlar vardı
Şartlar ne olursa olsun Onlar
içlerindeki güçleri yakalayacak Ve
sımsıkı tutacaklar Ben de o yıllarda
elimde olmayan sebeplerden dolayı
sürekli hızlanabilir dedim ya da
Hayatımda çok ciddi olarak olumsuz bir
anlam yükleyebilirim ama ben de belli ki
bugünün gençleri gibi içindeki güçleri
sömürmeye karar vermişim Baksanıza
geçmişlerdi Hatta o dinleyici olma
becerimiz bile benim önüme açabileceğini
düşünmem Evet kesinlikle psikoloji ve
Pedagoji bilim dalında duyduğum ilginin
bu becerini yakından ilgisi olduğunu
düşünüyorum yine o yıllarda
değiştiremeyeceğini şeylere takılma
değiştirebileceklerini Ak bu tutku ve
zekalı da zorla mutlu olmuştu hiçbir
zaman dış şartları suçlamadım Hatta
içinden geçmiş olduğum dönem benim en
büyük kampçı olmuştu
ben bir ihtilal dönemi genç kızı olarak
ülkeme ve benden sonra gelecek olanlara
Görevli idim Aslında Tıpkı Annem ve
babam gibi o zaman önümüzde iki yol var
ya hayatımızda
gerçekten sürekli dış şartları etmenleri
koşulları seçmedik lerimizi suçlayacak
ağız ya da kendi içinizdeki gücü
becerileri ilgileri tutkuları O
entellektüel ruhu tutacağız
yakalayacağız ve ona yolundan gideceğiz
şu anda hayatınızda yolunda gitmeyen bir
şeyler olabilir
hayatınızda yolunda gitmeyen bir şeyler
içinde dışarı yeni başlıyor
olabilirsiniz bu konuda haklı da
olabilirsiniz Ama başarılı olan
olamazsınız Biz peki Mutlu olabilir
misiniz
Sizin Neyi sizin harekete geçirdiğini
keşfetmeniz çok kıymetli olacak geleceği
ve dünyaya açılırken o içinizdeki keşfi
yapmanızı dilerim bunun çok kolay bir
şey olmadığını biliyorum Ama mümkün bir
şey olduğunu da biliyorum
Özgüven zor bir şey yapabildik ten ve
başarı girdikten sonra gelir Boğazı Şu
Uzun sıçrayış şehrinizde Bunu sakın
unutmayın olur mu Teşekkür ediyorum
Bildiklerim cumh